I youtubers I am Henriette for and I am
the director of United States foreign
assistance and the administrator for the
US Agency for International Development
and we are the largest bilateral donor
in the world and we try to reduce
poverty and to help people who are
struggling for freedom and people who
want to build their own lives and their
own nations so that we can have a better
future for all we've been here and Davos
talking about a number of issues all of
which are very important education and
agriculture and finance but let me tell
you about the global development Commons
that is an idea that is just beginning
to take root among the donor and
developing country community that you
could be a part of it is a way for
nonprofit organizations and individuals
and developing country ministers and
parents and school teachers and people
in every walk of life to come to a
Commons and talk about the issues that
are important to them in the Commons you
would be able to exchange information on
any issue of importance to you but
grouped around ideas that come out of
our development communities so ways to
increase prosperity and reduce poverty
that for the people in the developing
country we want to have nonprofit
organizations and businesses and
governments all come together on the
Commons let me give you an example in
the high mountains of Peru there are a
number of coffee growers these coffee
growers should know a great deal about
how to grow the finest coffee in the
world because coffee prices are rising
coffee demand is rising all of you
probably drink a cup of coffee at some
point in the day and you want to find a
cup of coffee
the buyers are worldwide who want to buy
coffee
so if our farmers who are poor and who
are in remote regions want to know about
what they have to do to grow the best
coffee bean and how to get it to market
we can get information to them through
the global development Commons so if you
want to keep your eye on this issue come
to WWE USAID gov thanks very much and be
a part of it